jennifer lopez and alex rodriguez have
called it quits
we really have a special connection that
way he was amazing
after a two-year engagement and four
years of dating
the couple confirmed their split in a
statement obtained by e.t
first reported by today we have realized
we are better as friends and look
forward to remaining so
we will continue to work together and
support each other on our shared
businesses and
projects they added quote we wish the
best for each other and one another's
children
out of respect for them the only other
comment we have
is to say thank you to everyone who has
sent kind words and support
i've learned so much from her in such a
short period of time prior to their
split
multiple sources told et on march 12
that the two had called off their
engagement
with one source noting that the 45 year
old former baseball pro and the 51 year
old triple threat
had decided their relationship quote had
run its course
but one day later a separate source told
et that the two were continuing their
relationship and
quote working through things adding that
quote no third party was involved
i think we're very alike in many ways
and i think that's what makes it work
we complement each other in a in a
beautiful way at the time
j-lo even mocked the breakup headlines
with this tick-tock video
i ain't worried about a blog you're done
speaking on my moves like this news you
will snitch
and a-rod he tagged jennifer in this
march 15th
instagram post writing new week new day
onward upward and on wednesday
he shared this video on his instagram
story
you can hear coldplay's fix you playing
as he films several framed photos with
jennifer and their kids
another source later told et that both
jennifer and alex's kids
wanted them to work things out of course
jen shares 13 year old twins emmy and
max with her ex mark anthony
while alex has two daughters 16 year old
natasha and 12 year old
ella from his past relationship my girls
adore jennifer she's she's a great role
model i'm the luckiest father in the
world to
to be able to expose my beautiful
daughters to someone as
brilliant as jennifer the source
explained quote their kids have grown to
be so
close and they are all hoping for the
[Music]
best
you